This little forge is made from
a paint can and some ceramic wool,
and is a cheap and easy way
to get started in beginning blacksmithing.
[Captions by Jeffrey D. at Y Translator]
[music]
Guys, I'm here with Grant.
This is not the Grant
you're used to seeing.
This is another Grant.
Grant, say hi.
>> Hello.
>> Today Grant is gonna be
showing us how we can build a forge
out of a paint can.
Grant, you've done this before right?
>> I've done it once yeah.
>> Wonderful.
So we've got a fantastic method
of building a forge out of a paint can,
and it doesn't use too many materials.
You wanna give us a rundown of what
materials we're going to be using?
>> So you're gonna need one paint can, um
you can use a big one or a little one.
>> These are available at
the hardware store.
I got this at Home Depot for about $5.
>> You'll need one alumina silicate
firebrick and one one foot by two foot
length of kaowool blanket.
We got four quarter inch
carriage bolts, 4 inches long,
we got gour 1/4 inch
and 2 and 1/2 inch long carriage bolts,
and 16 quarter inch hex nuts.
>> The fire brick is usually available online,
or at specialty refractory
materials stores.
Some places specialize in equipment
and materials to build things
like pizza ovens.
That's a great place to look.
Here's the basic idea.
Carriage bolts will be attached
to the paint can as feet to keep it off
the ground.
The inside of the can will be lined
with kaowool and a piece of firebrick
will act as the work surface.
A propane or matte gas torch will be our
heat source.
Grant, we've got all
of our materials ready.
What is gonna be the first step?
>> The first step is gonna remove
the inside lining of the paint can,
because if we don't,
it'll start burning when
we start using it later on,
and it's gonna smell really bad.
>> So these cans have sort of a plastic
lining and you can see that
it's a different color from the metal
and we need to burn all of that out.
Right now, Grant is using the propane
torch to burn the paint
from the outside of the can.
This is mostly because if you stick the
propane torch down inside of the can,
it burns up all of the oxygen and
then the torch goes out.
[music]
Our paint can is now all burned out.
We got rid of all the paint so I think
it's time to move on to the nextstep.
What do we do now?
>> We're gonna add four carriage
bolts as the feet.
>> We've got the four holes set up about
four inches apart in either direction.
[music]
We've got the four holes drilled in,
we've got our four carriage bolts.
Since we want a nut on
both sides of the paint can,
first, we need to thread one on far enough
that we can fit it on and then back it up.
Grab a pair of pliers just to make
sure that's nice and tight.
Now, we do that three more times.
At this point, you can see
the direction that this forge is going.
We're gonna have a nice
opening at one side
and the feet that let it stand up.
But we've also got four more
shorter carriage bolts.
Grant what are we using these for?
>> We're using these four smaller ones
to put on the bottom of the forge
so that we can then flip it over.
And it might be a mini foundry.
[Music]
We've now made something that
looks like a steel alien bug.
Is that what we were going for?
>> Yeah.
>> Perfect.
Then we nailed it.
What's next?
>> So we're gonna line the inside
now with kale wool.
And we're goinna put a piece
down at the bottom as well.
>> 7 and 1/2 inches by about 18 inches.
That's the measurements we're
getting for our paint can.
>> Technically, you're supposed to
wear a mask and and eye protection
when you're cutting this stuff.
So, we just thought we'd go overboard.
>> We'll also go outside.
[music]
So now let's curl this and see how
well it fits inside the can.
[music]
Hey look.
It fits.
Now we need a circle with a diameter
of about 3 and half maybe 4 inches.
[music]
All right we've got the can
lined with the kaowool.
Now we've got our fire brick.
What are we doing with this?
>> We're gonna cut it out.
to make a work surface to get
on the very center.
[music]
Just for aesthetic purposes,
we're gonna cut out some small triangle
pieces to fill these gaps.
[music]
Well neat.
That looks like it might work as a forge.
>> I think we're missing something.
That'll work.
>> So we need the fire
coming out of the torch
to be going through
the side of the paint can,
through the kale wool,
and then blowing fire
right down onto the brick.
We've got our line,
and we're gonna mark along there,
and we're going to put
the torch kind of near the front.
That way if we want to angle it
a little bit more forward, we can,
and if we want to twist it and angle
a little bit more backwards, we can.
If we have the torch too far back,
then we really only have the
option of angling it forward or down.
Further forward gives
us more space to play with it.
We are using 5/8 inch
forstner bit to drill our hole.
[music]
So at this point,
we can turn on the fire.
It's gonna get nice and hot in there
and we can use
this for blacksmithing right?
>> Yes you can.
>> Wonderful.
Is there anything else you want
to do with this can before we
say we're all finished?
>> Well we added these four
bolts on the bottom.
We want to turn it into a mini foundry.
We're gonna have to add a second hole.
>> Once again carefully drilling through
the kaowool without it twisting
and binding up and without
drilling into my fingers.
I choose to keep all of
my fingers for now.
Hopefully, forever.
Definitely for now.
Aha!
And now it's a little foundry.
So we've now got
two holes in our foundry,
and you say we should
have a small kaowool plug.
Yeah to just plug whichever
one we're not using.
>> Exactly.
>> All right.
Well I've got this little spare piece.
Let's cut a plug out of it.
>> Yeah.
>> There.
Plugged.
Now, when we're using it as a forge,
the fire won't come out of here,
and when we're using it as a foundry,
we can just move the plug and then
the fire won't come out of here.
For the convenience of space
we've come outside.
We've got a piece of railroad track and
we're gonna be using this as an anvil.
Let's test if our forge gets hot enough that
we can soften metal and begin to shape it.
Grant, I have a question.
You have no glove on the hand
that's holding the steel,
but you are wearing
a glove on the other hand.
What's up with that?
>> When you're working with hot steel,
you wanna grab the metal
with a bare hand
because if you're wearing a glove,
or a plastic glove or something,
you might not feel it's super hot,
and it might burn the leather or the plastic
right into your flesh.
So you just wanna keep it bare skin.
So you know how hot and how
not the steel is.
Uh with the hammer,
I just you don't need a glove.
I just use one because it's for padding.
Let's flatten it.
I'd say it's pretty flat.
>> That's flat!
I mean you could we can make it into
a very large flat-head screwdriver.
Grant thanks for coming out and showing
us how to build this little foundry.
>> You're welcome.
>> I'm hoping that sometime
in the future, we can have you back,
and you can show us some
of the things we can do with this.
Maybe a little bit of
introductory blacksmithing.
>> I'd love to, yeah.
>> Guys, we've still got
more for you to see.
That box up at the top will transport
you directly to our last video,
go check that out.
The box in the bottom will show you what
YouTube thinks you should be watching now,
and this bomb here in the middle
will subscribe you to our channel.
So you never miss a video.
Don't forget to ring that bell and
we'll see you in the next one.
Talk to you then.